this Hollywood babble-on with your hosts
Kevin Smith and Ralph Garman Vogue
magazine had the big get the big
interview with the Bieber's mr. and mrs.
Bieber Oh get out of Justin and Haley
sat down for a big interview with Vogue
magazine with vogue yes I believe I
won't be reading that they got photos to
any leap of it shot some photos here's
one of the two and then look at them
look at those two [ __ ] Mensa members
right there huh you won't believe this
interview when you're ready you really
you genuinely won't believe it the
couple who has been married for four
months talks about how difficult
marriage is how in four months holy SH
marriage is very hard it's hard yo first
of all Haley Bieber that's the sentence
you should lead with it's really effing
hard they've been married for four
months I've drank all the scissor P oh
wow man yeah good luck Bieber said I'm
not gonna sit here in lies say it's all
magical fantasy it's always gonna be
hard it's a choice you don't feel it
every day though you don't wake up every
day saying oh I'm absolutely so in love
and you're perfect that's not what being
married is in the first four months it
is they're so [ __ ] oh my god that's
like when that's eight minutes clearly
they haven't [ __ ] seven times about
parently not Bieber's need some of that
drug you've been taken that's yeah man
[ __ ] they're already in counseling by
the way that's a good sign right
are you [ __ ] me I'm so happy I can't
wait for them to explode I mean look
let's not shame
counseling yeah
Bieber also opened up about his life pre
marriage he said things were not ago I
wasn't married yo right he said I found
myself doing things I was ashamed of
being super promiscuous and stuff who
was that mean he [ __ ] a lot of girls
that's what you think it means I
he's like no he's not eating a corn on
the cob I think I use an axe because I
was so ashamed he said my mom always
said to treat women with respect for me
that was always in my head while I was
doing it so I could never enjoy it oh
poor bastard having sex with all those
models and he couldn't enjoy it because
his mom's voice was ringing in his head
is that what it reads like to you yeah I
found myself doing things I was ashamed
of being super promiscuous and stuff and
I think he's thanks because those shows
hey my mom always said to treat women
with respect for me that was always in
my head while I was doing it so I could
never enjoy it he is talking about like
mom says he was being nice to what mom
said coming me Justin not be nice gotta
be respectful yo wow man drugs put a
screen between me and what I was doing
no I think he's talking about the drug
yeah no no that was the sex septal here
they talks about doing the drugs so he
could have sex with the women
what yes he had to get high to have
promiscuous sex because mama was still
talking in his ear some nights literally
Justin toe didn't be respectful put your
dick away Justin it got pretty dark I
think there were times when my security
was coming in late at night to check my
pulse and see if I was still breathing
we were so close
one xanax away from the big party
[Music]
you
[Music]